Salut !  Aujourd'hui on est Vendredi, le vendredi je donne des cours de guitare maintenant.
Pas du tout, et heureusement pour vous.
Mais aujourd'hui je suis avec Olivier Hecho
Salut,Olivier !
- Salut Fabien.
- et ta guitare.
et à cause de toi tout le monde va encore dire que je suis petit, combien tu mesures ?
1 mètre 65... Non,, 1 mètre....
(rire)
1 mètre 90
T'as une chaine dans la vie ou tu donnes des cours de guitare, tu expliques comment on joue,
- Exactement, des cours de guitare, des démos de guitare aussi
Ben merci d'être venu chez moi
- Merci à toi de m'inviter
Et moi je vais prendre ta guitare et je vais te mentaliser
- Mentaliser la guitare ?
Elle pense à un La mineur...
On va faire un truc à base d'accords et à base de mémoire corporelle
puisque toi si je te dis "SOL" majeur" par exemple,
dans ta tête ton cerveau sait exactement comment contracter tes muscles pour faire un SOL...
- Oui c'est vrai
On va essayer de jouer avec ça, c'est une grande première j'ai réflechi à ça ce matin
je me suis dit il y Olivier qui vient à la maison
Donc toi tu peux penser à des accords dans ta tête, des accords majeurs, des accords mineurs, etc...
en l'occurence, moi ce que je veux
pour le premier coup c'est des accords majeurs,
-D'accord, d'accord, oui oui c'est clair.
pour le premier coup on va essayer ça
c'est drôle parce que vraiment, je n'ai jamais essayé
- je ne sais pas ce qu'il va dire...
- Je vais devenir un manche de guitare,
Ok Olivier ?  Alors je vais me mettre ici...
Tu es droitier ou gaucher ? - Droitier
donc tu tiens tu guitare comme ça
- Oui comme ça oui
et tu donnes le rythme ici...
donc ça, ça va être un manche de guitare, d'accord ?
je vais te demander d'enchaîner les accords
tu les enchaînes et tu peux gratter dans le vide dans ta tête,
comme si tu les enchaînais, tu les tiens autant de temps que tu veux, c'est la
rythmique que tu veux.
- Donc je fais des accords hein ?
- oui, je ne regarde pas ta main j'essaye juste de ressentir hein.
ok. Bon là en fait c'est facile, je ne pensais pas que çà serait aussi facile
mais même à la sensation j'ai trouvé ça simple, tu as commencé par un FA,
- Exact... - Après tu as enchaîné avec un LA majeur
- Oui... - Et un DO.
- Exact !
Donc tu nous as fait une petite feinte avec un FA majeur, un LA, et un DO.
Bon, écoute, à ressentir c'était encore plus simple que ce que je pensais,
- Ah oui ?  - Oui je pensais que ça serait plus difficile, tiens je vais te le faire d'ailleurs...
- C'est pas si évident pourtant.... enfin je ne sais pas...
Tu fais d'autres accords ? Tu ne me dis pas ?
- Oui...
je vais te faire un... je vais te faire un....
ah bah c'est super dur ! Je ne sais même pas combien il y a de doigts là....
ah c'est un Mi mineur !
- Ah oui, c'etait pas si simple, alors ?
- Ah non, c'est difficile, franchement, non non.....
Pour le deuxième coup, on va faire plus compliqué.
Donc tu connais des chansons en 4 ou 3 accords,
Tu peux en avoir une en 3 accords ?
- Oui...
- Ok. Une chanson en 3 accords....
je vais essayer de la retrouver, mais ça va être plus difficile
ce coup-ci tu vas garder les mains exactement dans la position comme ça...
Ah alors là on ne te verrait pas, alors peut-être juste comme ça.
Ta main gauche, voilà.... Alors tu vas mettre ta main gauche comme ça,
Et tu vas jouer rapidement les 3 accords, c'est-à-dire, moi je vais te faire 1-2-3
C'est comme si moi je faisais : 1 accord, 2 accords, 3 accords.
Et comme si tu les plaçais sur le manche... voilà.
Le plus spontanément possible...
- A quel moment ?
- Quand je vais dire TOP :
C'est parti !
Maintenant !
Ok.
Je pense l'avoir.
Je pense l'avoir...
Est-ce que tu reconnais bien les accords à l'oreille ?
Ah j'ai pas l'oreille absolue mais je vais les reconnaître, là !
Je peux regarder ou pas ?
- Nan. -Ok
Je dirais que le premier, ca fait ça :
(fausse note)
Euh...attends....
Ca c'est ca qu'on appelle une fausse note !
- Ca c'est un accord non classé !
Alors je dirais que le premier c'est ça :
(beaucoup mieux) - Oui...
C'est un DO, c'est correct ?
-Exact, oui...
J'aurais dit que le deuxième, c'était ça :
(accord mélodieux) - Exact !
Donc c'est un FA
Et que le troisième c'était ça :
(joue une petite mélodie) - Exact !
Et c'est quoi comme chanson ?
- Ah ben, c'est ça :
Caaaaaa....
(joue)
Tu vas me faire danser, ils vont adorer !
(rire)
Ecoute je ne sais pas si ça t'as bluffé, mais j'espère au moins que ça t'as plu !
Ah c'est plus que bluffant ! - C'est vrai ?
- Vraiment ! carrément ! Il a un oeil d'aigle !
Olivier il a vraiment une chaîne où il explique des fois des chansons ou des trucs sur la guitare,
Et je le suis sur sa chaîne, je vous recommande de faire pareil
Je vais vous mettre une petite fiche juste ici, pour que vous vous abonniez à sa chaîne
Et merci à vous de nous avoir regardés dans cette vidéo qui mélangeait guitare et mentalisme
C'etait une grande première, moi ça m'a plu en tout cas de me stimuler à chercher des idées à faire avec toi, c'était cool
Si la vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir en laissant un petit... Comment on appelle ça dans les accords,
on appelle ça le POUCE EN L'AIR !
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne, et rendrez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog,
Parce que c'est UNE VIDEO PAR JOUR pendant UN AN,
TCHAO !